um
I just want to let you all know that we
have this room here
you see this room look we got a desk
uh we got a desk got two desks right you
guys see Field of Dreams if you build it
they will come this room is a room for
web people you can see that the word op
has been crossed out and we're looking
for web people uh we're looking to hire
two people
um front end back end Azure react
uh
if you're interested
on site in San Diego as usual uh so
we're getting to the point where
disengagement analysis is starting to
matter
uh hello oh my uh we're getting to the
point where disengagement analysis is
starting to matter meaning the dream of
Explorer uh is finally going to be
realized but we need to improve Explorer
we need to figure out we need to give
users a good way of basically labeling
mistakes then we're going to add
mistakes to our data set we also have
another web tool called Cabana Cabana
lets you look at the can buses of cars
look we just need these things to be
good uh with the shutting down of comma
Europe we lost a web guy
so when we lose one we're gonna we're
gonna hire two
uh see we have one we have this desk
here
uh for our for a web guy and we have
this desk here for a web guy or girl you
know we we think discrimination is bad
uh all kinds of discrimination sucks so
we don't do that uh we only discriminate
based on skill uh so you know you got to
have skill
um
yeah that's pretty much it
that's pretty much all I gotta say we're
hiring for a web guy see this is the
room for web people connect Azure web
and other web I don't know why this is
Rip Cabana but I think it's because we
don't have any web people
uh so yeah we're trying to hire two web
people uh
we're trying to hire
in the operations uh division we're
always trying to hire uh trying to hire
a head of supply chain uh if you do
reach in for how to supply chain and you
have a lot of like
whenever people talk about passion or
things like that I'm just like oh this
ain't it bro uh you know just someone
who wants to be honest and wants to be
uh ruthless with our suppliers
uh
and make sure we could get the best
price on things you know and also like
another thing for how to supply chain I
need someone who knows every component
of a cell phone right I'm going to ask
you what's on a cell phone and you're
going to give me a list and then you're
like you mentioned something like flash
and I'm going to be like well what kind
of flash right and like you better know
like what you know ufs is right uh and
then I ask you who makes it you could be
like Samsung and SK hay next right I'm
literally going to ask those questions
so but maybe I'll ask it about other
components
uh so you know I gotta you gotta know
these things uh if you want to be had a
supply chain uh we're also hiring an
office manager
uh uh yeah uh if you want if you want to
work here as an office manager uh uh sit
at our receptionist desk
uh you know that kind of stuff
man you're right it is nand that's right
that's right it is an end now how many
LCS is it SLC mlc or TLC can you please
tell me what that is thank you uh so
yeah you gotta know these things right
um that's what we got uh we're hiring
yeah yeah Cabana and explore are fun uh
you thought managers suck what do you
mean
supply chain head of supply chain
that's that's that's the phrase we're
looking for
uh we're also look if again a web
a website too I want like I want like a
website so if you're more on the design
side of things uh you could totally uh
work in this room as well
um
yeah we're moving to webflow for the
website uh but you know just some basic
server knowledge ability to deploy
things make them work make them look
nice check for bugs all that kind of
stuff
uh so yeah we're hiring uh jobs at comma
dot AI you'll be given a programming
challenge
uh I don't know if these things work
sometimes you know sometimes we just get
lucky man it's like dating you know you
just gotta you gotta you gotta sometimes
you get lucky man sometimes you're like
wow I can't believe I'm at this person
so I'm hoping that'll be you uh uh come
work here you can work in room 51.
room 51 can be your room if you're the
first person here you can have this
whole room to yourself it's a really
nice room
has a great view of the outside got a
window with some sunlight our old office
no windows and sunlight new office lots
of Windows and sunlight
um no no nothing remote we don't do
remote work
um like Elon says you can pretend to
work somewhere else
uh in person San Diego
uh salary ranges from like 80 to 140
depending on how much Equity you want
I gotta post to salary ranges now it's
California I don't know why we took it
down I'm always Pro posting the salary
range if you're looking to make you know
350k go work at Fang uh if you're
looking to write cool open source
software I can work here
uh no no no no no no no I'm parking
extreme
um
oh we have some very exciting
announcements in the body department
they might have to wait for CES though
uh C plus plus libtorch
uh uh coming from
yeah I mean look we would it's not
really here's the thing like we don't
really hire programmers much based on
language uh I don't really care about
language you're good at programming's a
universal skill you'll pick up any
language uh pretty quickly uh so yeah
we're not gonna
um regardless of what
language you are good at apply uh and
you'll be asked pretty generic questions
about computers and how they work
uh yeah comma's expanding we are we are
um
a large corporation now
uh
uh yeah
that's it we're we're getting harassed
by a patent troll
uh that's happening uh you know it's
just like man I'm not someone you want
to mess with like really
uh but you know we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna we're gonna do that right
um how do you guys feel about patent
troll awareness week it's probably the
first time I've said it but I I think
that it'll be a a good event we'll get
some hats that say never settle you know
how many you would buy a never settle
hat
like some nice some nice never settle
merch
um
but yeah we are hiring Two web
developers one to sit at this desk and
one to sit at this desk and whoever
comes here first can move this TV metal
we probably have a TV in here too we'll
probably set up a TV with some metrics
I'll be pretty nice you got a Zuckerberg
you know what I can't say that anymore I
can't say you got a Zuckerberg because
look at Mata stock oh man I lost some
money on that too
um full self-driving timeline soon soon
uh
uh yeah there's one plus this tagline
all right thanks
um
uh
uh no it's a generic phrase never settle
um
what was I gonna say oh when is full
self-driving coming we're working on it
uh we need better testing you know it's
all about testing and testing starts
with uh being able to annotate a lot of
mistakes uh so this is what the web team
will be building
um data Gathering
uh yeah our slogans make driving chill
I think we gotta we gotta stream for 10
minutes in order to hit the YouTube
monetization
um what's today AI day yeah we'll see
let's see what tells us to say uh
we're not really hiring for if you're
really really good
um we'll hire you for research but
that's the hardest division to get hired
for if you want to get hired for open
pilot uh contribute things to the open
pilot repo and if you want to get hired
for the web division just reach into
jobs.com.ai we're also hiring an office
manager and head of supply chain
uh for office manager I mean that's you
know you're an office manager you know
what that is be organized be
conscientious all those kind of things
uh for how to supply chain know all the
components inside of a cell phone
absolutely we have paid internships
um
the thing about the paid internships is
it's only well
no if look if you're good you want to
intern here oh it's similar to most tech
companies
but the internships are our working
experiences not learning experiences I
mean everything's a learning experience
too but uh you know we had one intern
there was a bit of a confusion you know
wow you go to work
uh you hear the prettiest value
you'll buy a comma three of Tesla
mentions comma I don't think Tesla's
going to mention comma uh
yeah comma three is uh by Common threes
if you haven't bought a Combat 3 yet by
comma three uh you know before the price
goes up I don't know if the price is
going to go up but if it does you know
you'll be like man I bought my comma
three before the price went up that's
how common two people felt
uh
cool that's 10 minutes thank you for
watching the video uh jobs.com AI uh
come work here uh
we shouldn't really do visas for interns
anymore we might still again again look
if you're good enough uh everything can
be can be worked out
um I have met Elon
uh zero nine this year this year's
Anna's gonna be this year uh best car
for comma three
probably uh I mean the curl is very good
too
uh should we do ads should we should we
start advertising for products no not
yet no yeah we gotta we gotta lower the
cost we're working on lowering the cost
and one of the ways to do that is we're
hiring a head of supply chain
um you have end of the year and your
Tesla bingo today no no zero nine by the
end of the year right uh solving
self-driving is going to take another
four years
uh you know it takes 10 years it's gonna
take 10 years uh we've been in business
six I think in about four years we're
gonna be like yeah you know what guys we
kind of saw self-driving
uh so there there's a real estimate on
when you know just extrapolating some
Trends been reading a lot of papers
dreamer V2 Iris
um the the dream of learning a driving
simulator if you read comma published a
paper in 2016 uh if you read that paper
that dream is finally becoming possible
uh five years later like five years
later people are actually starting to
make architectures that look like that
autoencoders work Transformers work in
2016 Auto encoders were like look we can
generate a five from mnist and now an
auto encoders like bro stable diffusion
uh so you know they're a lot better
always azure because they give us the
most free money
uh
uh Google gave us no free money AWS give
us some free money and it has to give us
a lot of free money so we went with
Azure I like free money you know that uh
we don't have any free money anymore we
actually paid them so you know worked
for them right I think actually it was
actually probably worthwhile there are
total lifetime values of customers
probably uh worthwhile are we buying 40
90s yeah maybe you know we buy h100s or
whatever they're called right
uh well actually if anyone finds any
blower 4090s I'm very interested
um one of the problems is the only 40
90s I've seen are these massive three
slot non-blower ones
uh so we need we need two slot blower
4090s
or we might have to transition to water
cooling
all right we have 85 people here we've
already kind of gone over time uh this
was just supposed to be quick to talk
about how we have one desk here and one
desk here and we will get chairs as well
uh we're doing another Comic-Con yeah
maybe you know it's a lot of work maybe
we can do it right here at this
beautiful office
uh yeah we'll water cool the gpus I mean
they just draw so much power now too
common needs AI day
and Comic-Con was AI day go watch all
the Comic Con presentations we explained
everything we're doing
you know
the truth is I don't even do that much
here anymore oh yeah check out our UniFi
um
I don't really do that much here anymore
I'm like it's already all figured out
you know the whole plans figured out we
just gotta like
slowly move forward and fix all the bugs
and then one day we're going to be like
oh my God we solve self-driving cars
right remember that time like it's like
go right like it's slow and there's a
lot of pieces to it you got to make them
all work and you got to fix all the bugs
and then one day
yo we still have to go and it's gonna be
like that fish self-driving cars
um sounds like I'm the current supply
chain head uh
uh I do play chess but I'm only like a
1200 I'm not that good
uh
what is going on with comma points
nothing what's my main role head
cheerleader it's been that for a while
um
yeah we have one desk here
uh and one desk over here
uh to come work here and work on web
and yeah I mean like I said the point of
web is to
allow us to uh really start to annotate
our data with with the release of zero
nine so you guys know what zero nine is
going to have right
um first we're going to push the
software and boom level four
self-driving cars I don't say level four
anymore that just has to do with
liability bro ask about common points
again and get banned uh
all right all right all right all right
we got Fanboys Man Fan boiler it was a
class on
ah
God the only Fanboys watch this [ __ ]
operating with a car manufacturer oh my
God my plan is to solve AI okay first
self-driving cars then AI
uh
uh
first self-driving cars then AI
uh a web Tech stack
it's react uh I think it's the kind of
stuff I'm least familiar with I mean you
can look it's open source you can check
out Cabana and explore on our website uh
do we use scrum I don't really know what
that is what like some some agile or
something like that no we like you know
you
we have very small teams who work on
each project
uh uh yeah I like the sweater
AI on what I mean look I want to build I
want to build a person
right I want to build like I want to
stand next to a person I I know it's
react yeah I don't know specifically
more than that
um
is it typescript I don't know
um it's not that different
what will I do after self-driving and
robots what there's nothing else we're
going to solve AI
the AI person thing is whack why do you
think that bro how about an AI dog what
if we start with an AI dog would you
like an AI dog
I want to be God look we're gonna yeah I
want to solve AI right
I mean I wanted to solve AI since I was
15.
and like here we are it takes a really
long time to actually do anything it
turns out but uh yeah we're gonna do it
longevity and biotech they think about
that is you just have the AI do it for
you uh does a common Model come with
pre-trained features what do you mean we
proposed all the way to open source
can use the weights common Dynamics yeah
yeah yeah no I'm serious
um all neural based on device learning I
wrote some blog posts about this
um no no no that's not the difference
between a dog and an AI person the
person has like
a 100x the compute of a dog 10x at least
why do I need to sell my soul to VCS man
our our rounds have been increasingly
giving away less and less equity for
more and more money look the truth is
not that many people are actually doing
things in the world
when we release like you've seen how
good the comma 3 is right you're seeing
how good open pile it is who can I how
many teams in the world are capable of
building things that are that complex
and making them work that well not that
many
um
see I mean there's a myth about like
that you need you know why someone said
this on Twitter they're like uh in order
for comma to succeed you guys are going
to need uh hyper scale you guys are
going to need uh tons of investment this
is a capital intensive business it's not
a capital intensive business this is
completely wrong
um was solving go a capital intensive
business it wasn't right solving
self-driving cars is the same
it's it's a the code Carmack talks about
this the code for AGI is probably going
to be like 10 000 lines right uh in the
realm of where an individual can write
it even
um now I think it's helpful to have like
testing and uh support from a team
um but I don't think that team has to be
very large I promise you it's under the
Dunbar number
uh so yeah
no I don't think you need some I do not
understand how these tech companies have
thousands of people working there
like you look you take like a stupid SAS
tech company and over a thousand people
work there and you're like what do they
do all day
um I don't know Ma po algorithm
what do I think the algorithm will be
um
like I like it's probably not something
we exactly have a name for now uh you
know it's gonna be soft actor critic
version nine
um I mean these concepts are going to
exist for a really long time the idea of
like a Dynamics model and a
representation model and a policy model
are we bottlenecked by Hardware no not
really
I mean better Hardware is always nicer
and you can pave over this is I mean the
same thing was true in like graphics and
everything with better Hardware you can
pave over crappier software
um the better the better the hardware is
the less efficiently you have to write
things the less close to the edge you
are so this will get easier over time as
Hardware gets better but are we
bottlenecked by Hardware I mean like not
really
you know it's all just uh
it's all just a slow and steady grind
forward right uh like you think you
think about what was done on the old um
end-to-end longitudinals coming to the
common three
uh
and yeah I mean you'll say
Intel longitude is gonna be crazier than
that lateral you're not going to believe
some of the things it does and you know
what no one else can believe it either
because like you can code a pretty
competent lateral policy you can't cut a
confident longitudinal policy
um
I mean I was going to end this stream
but we keep getting more people can you
tell your friends come work here
like who thinks we're gonna win
who thinks we're gonna win
who thinks we're gonna win AI
thank you
uh right yeah
I mean let's start if I solving
self-driving cars right
uh was an example of something
anti-launchy and we'll do that's
surprising well like humans break very
differently for a stop car to red light
and a stop card a green light
all right
um no we're not releasing the 3D printer
files for the coming too uh don't fold
and you will eventually right yeah just
slow and steady progress
ah yeah I mean we have to we'll pass
Tesla at some point I think
um yeah exploring cavana needs some new
designs I agree
[Music]
um
you don't but you have a chance well
thank you I mean you know there's a
chance we won't win of course but uh
hiring amazing talents like 10x harder
than fire I think people here are very
smart
um
higher car path yeah carpathy wants a
job you know I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
Shield him about that
um but yeah if it's interesting
uh whether you're toggle in a17 foreign
that's the definition of zero nine
uh no the device CPU will not be
upgradable where are you from bro in the
80s the 90s I think that's only the 90s
in the 80s you couldn't upgrade the CPUs
there was just some weird error in the
90s in the early 2000s where you could
upgrade like CPUs and RAM and stuff
um there's no age cut off what do you
mean what do you think I'm gonna like I
said discrimination's stupid man I'm not
discriminating on anything but skill
uh what an always-on lcast getting more
data now in fact the only data we train
on is the data from Human driving
uh I would probably only hire two
percent of zoox's employees
uh can I make money from alpha full two
no well I don't want to do that
but it's just some like IQ like there's
some supervised like that's one of the
more boring things the deepmind did so
much cool stuff and then like Alpha
Falls kind of like
oh we did supervised learning on protein
folding yeah
eh
eh
um I think that's one of the more
mediocre things they did
like yes you can make that work no one
doubts you can make that work the
question is like okay did it Advance the
state of the art and AI
um I mean look Nvidia
I like a low stock price Nvidia low
stock price Nvidia nice Nvidia High
stock price Nvidia dick and video all
right that's just that's just the Nvidia
um you guys know I'm excited for the
recession
it's getting more easy for you to hire
good people over time no it's been
pretty constant it's been the same
um
do you have another chip maker I've been
quite upset with Qualcomm
the companies are impossible to work
with I think that there's going to be
some good Chinese upstarts in two years
we're talking like Risk five nvdla uh
Mali gpus some licensed GPU uh
maybe tends to aren't maybe I mean come
on Jim you got it you gotta ship the
chip man they gotta ship the chip I'm
happy to use transformient we're going
to need more uh neural network
um yeah I think Qualcomm is making some
bad choices uh I think Nvidia I mean
Nvidia might even come around Nvidia
might even come around their new Psalms
are much more reasonable than anything
they previously shipped uh if you guys
saw the the Oren Nano
it's 200 it's on the verge of shippable
um
I'm gonna say my stable to Fusion one
art
uh photonic why why do I need that
uh
I kind of want to make a chip
not the cut not for the comma form but
for the comma five we'll make a joke
so the common for the comma five will
make a we'll make a risk five chip
um a common four we're gonna have to buy
from somebody I hope some I hope some
Chinese manufacturer Rock Chip all
winner uh is like we're gonna make a
serious chip it's sadly it's getting
more expensive to buy the like the The
Cutting Edge wafers
[Music]
um
open pilot and autopilot are just
different things they're they're
optimizing for different things they're
both very good at what they do
uh
yeah you can you know for people who've
used both you can read there's tons of
comparisons on the internet
I don't know it's just as boring to me
like I mean the product's kind of cool
like the product's pretty cool but like
they're real cool things they're the
solution to AI
did you miss a comma three plan oh after
the comma three we're gonna be on the
common three for two more years
but we're gonna be able to come through
for two hours it's not there's zero
motivation here to Port to a different
platform
um
um like there's there's a lot of work to
still do on like newer variants of the
comma three
uh that have really just down costed
stuff
where can you buy a comma body at comma
body.com
ship to me
um comma 2.5 no that's so boring guys
every time I think about these things
I'm like oh I'm bored I'm bored you know
you make it man you make it open source
I'll just make design your own Hardware
make it oh it's so easy man just do it
um
no like here's my dream for comma in
like 10 years you go to the comma store
at the mall and you walk out with like
like like a a friend who comes home and
cooks for you and cleans for you I loves
you yeah that's my dream that's my
long-term dream
um
maybe we'll we'll start with a dog
when can you buy a comma body right now
on comma body.com go click buy it's 9.99
Now is it going to cook and clean for
you no don't get your hopes off is it
going to stand there in Balance yes
they've loaded appropriately with
software and paired to the comma three
yeah
all right this has gone on way too long
the yes we're hiring for web this desk
and this desk
um
we're hiring for infrastructure
uh yeah absolutely we're always hiring
for infrastructure
uh Greg's very picky about who we hire
for infrastructure uh you know really
really
uh Senior People ready to ready to hit
the ground running
um so spend money on weird scary robot
yeah
come a body with an app store for all
your household choice but I won't need
an app store you just teach it you know
on device learning man
um EV trucks no we just we're pushing
any EVS we support the bolt now we
support the ev6
ah
I don't care about iPhone security
anymore
it's the nation-state
solve AI yeah that's interesting
it's kind of the only problem with
solving you know
I mean everyone thinks about it really
kind of says this what what else is what
else is really worth solving in the
world
um
AI
well yeah of course it'll love you you
know everyone needs a friend man be a
therapist it'll listen to your problems
right that's that's where we're going
with these things
all right all right now that we've
gotten through investment advice thank
you for watching the stream we're hiring
two people for web a head of supply
chain uh an office manager and look if
you can convince me you can do something
else here to add value I'm interested if
you want to work for free you actually
want an education uh and you got to pay
for that and we don't provide education
but if you want to come here get a job
we pay you you do work you increase the
value of the company capitalism all
right thanks for watching bye guys